when you think of country music
who do you think of maybe it's dolly
parton belting jolene
or tim mcgraw's iconic southern drawl
maybe it's something a little bit more
modern like taylor swift's love story
which got a revival on tick tock this
past summer
or maybe gabby barrett's top billboard
country song
i hope or maybe let's be honest
you just think of white people when you
look at the country charts
black artists are far and few between
but
that doesn't mean they don't exist and
actually in many ways
black people in america have helped
shape country music to what it is today
even if they don't always get the
recognition for it
[Applause]
[Music]
for many historians the origins of
modern day country music
begin with bluegrass relies on the
acoustic sounds of string instruments
and the banjo is a staple the banjo is a
west
african instrument brought over in the
1600s via the transatlantic slave trade
the instruments were originally made out
of boards and had been popular in the
region
way before american slavery started
other instruments like the fiddle and
tambourine
were also integral to bluegrass and also
had links to africa now as enslaved
africans were forced into the americas
they continued to make these instruments
but black influence
didn't stop there
work calls and chants became lyrics to
these sounds
and these chants also known as
spirituals
helped to tell stories keep the pace and
secretly spread information for example
the songs of the underground railroad
had secret coded directions to help
slaves escape to the north fast forward
a few hundred years
and take this lyrical storytelling
element with this acoustic string
sound and you got the foundation of
country music
now while these spirituals were
essential to a slave's motivation
survival and possible freedom how did
this music enter into mainstream
white southern culture the answer
blackface by the 1800s
music created by black people became
popular within mainstream white music
and minstrel shows helped bring these
songs to the spotlight
well well sort of well let me explain
you see
mitchell shows were like oh gee american
theater
they usually would consist of variety
comedy shows
think snl but like super racist
since black performers weren't allowed
in white spaces
white performers would paint their faces
black play the banjo
fiddle and other bluegrass instruments
and perform
satirical slave songs and dances they
would do skits
and speeches in exaggerated black
southern dialects
so essentially they stripped african
slaves of their tribal cultures
made it illegal for them to speak their
native language made
reading english punishable by lashings
or worse
and then created a theatrical art form
to make fun of them
for the music and dialects they were
forced to create for themselves
yep that's about right mitchell shows
helped solidify
a lot of negative black stereotypes and
it was still seen in film
all the way up to the mid 20th century
but despite the overall harm the
satirical genre
did for the black community black music
was starting to be taken seriously by
white people for the first time
and mainly because it was introduced to
them in this non-threatening way
unfortunately there was no credit or
representation given to the black artist
that helped create the music
another precursor to modern day country
music and a lot of other genres
was the blues which got its start in the
1860s
as minstrel shows were starting to come
down from their peak the sad
sultry minor tones within the slave
spirituals made its way into the genre
these spiritual call and response based
lyrics were a way to create more unity
and inclusion within the music
experience
and that carried over into blues as well
now there are tons and tons of black
blues artists
but many of them didn't get white
mainstream acceptance until the
following century
and even then they weren't given the
same performance privileges as their
white counterparts
and this inequality was the same in many
other genres that were developing during
the 20th century
like jazz rock and yeah country
there has been and continue to be black
country artists
country music is a blend of many
different cultures and genres
but history doesn't always reflect this
things get a little messy
once you learn that these iconic white
artists actually got their trade from
other black artists
hank williams was mentored by rufus top
johnny cash was taught from an early age
by gus cannon
and black guitar player leslie riddle
was known as one of the pioneers of the
finger-picking guitar style
favored by mabel carter and while legal
segregation has been outlawed in the
united states since the 1960s
americans still have trouble giving
black artists credit within the country
genre
[Music]
moving into the 80s 90s and 2000s black
country artists weren't charting and
country music had been seen
socially as a white genre and
internalized prejudice within music
management
didn't really help in 1998 general
manager
of curb records dennis hannon insisted
that quote
for country music to be more
well-rounded we would like to see more
african-american artists
but he also said if it is harder for
african-american artists to break into
the industry it's more of a lifestyle
issue
likewise in 2006 tammy genovese of the
country music association
rejected a reporter's suggestion that
the industry had not attempted to gain
black fans
telling the guardian quote the black
community's lifestyle
is different from what we communicate
with country music
black people have their own types of
music that they listen to
be that jazz hip-hop or whatever
country singers in nashville formed to
create the black country music
association in the mid-1990s
in hopes of giving black artists an
avenue into the genre
country singer cleve francis was one of
the founders and described the nashville
country music industry
as one based solely on quote permission
when it came to the black artist there
francis himself had suffered from racism
in the industry
especially at the hands of those who
were supposed to be in charge of
marketing and managing his career
despite these attempts at inclusion
the genre today still faces hardships
when it comes to representation
atlanta rapper little nas x shattered
records with his debut hit old town road
in 2019
from the topic to the twangy tone it was
as his producer described
a country rap song
[Music]
and at first billboard agreed he was
ranked on the billboard country charts
before billboard decided to retract his
ranking
and exclude him from the category
billboard told rolling stone
quote while old town road incorporates
references to country and cowboy imagery
it does not embrace enough elements of
today's country music
to chart in its current version this was
definitely
not the first time a hip-hop artist
attempted to enter into country
and was rejected nellie and tim mcgraw
both southern artists made over and over
in 2004
[Music]
it made not even a blip on the country
charts beyonce's daddy lessons on
lemonade was a
textbook country bop
the song's thematic storytelling and use
of traditional country instrumentals fit
well into the genre
which led her to performing the song at
the 2016 cmas
but country fans were pissed according
to the ap
beyonce also tried to submit the record
for a country grammy
and the submission was rejected but this
sort of exclusion doesn't stop
at hip-hop or r b artists attempting to
enter into the country space
mickey gaiden a rising black female
country artist has commented both on the
racism that faces black country artists
and also the industry's sexism
[Music]
[Music]
she said quote i don't even realize how
crazy what i'm doing is
it really is hard for women to get
played on country radio
periods do i face extra obstacles
absolutely from the slave trade to
beyonce black people have been
shaping and contributing to country
music since the start
and while the united states has made
some progress in black representation in
some genres of music and entertainment
it's important that history provides a
holistic depiction
of all of our contributions because
black history
is american history
[Music]
you